it's relatively common for actors to go
to great lengths to inhabit the
characters they portray in pursuit of a
dynamic performance they'll conduct
extensive research learn new skills and
even alter their appearance for some
performers their experiences onset ended
up dramatically altering the course of
their own lives
here are some of the actors whose lives
were permanently changed after they took
on a particular role Jim Carrey to land
the role of comedian Andy Kaufman in
1999's man on the moon Jim Carrey
reportedly cut his 20 million dollar fee
in half and wasn't too proud to audition
for the part after he signed on he went
fully method' living as Kaufman instead
of Carrey he told the LA Times I broke a
couple of times on weekends and stuff
but pretty much from when I woke up to
when I went to bed the choices were all
Kaufman's
Carrie's performance would forever
change the way he looked at the world
and led to an existential crisis it was
over I couldn't remember who I was
anymore so you step through the door not
knowing what's on the other side what's
on the other side is everything the
actor has continued to question the
nature of reality and the meaning of
celebrity years later he was interviewed
at New York Fashion Week and said I
wanted to find the most meaningless
thing that I could fun come to and join
and Here I am brie Larson for the
intense 2015 drama room 3 Larson
underwent a punishing routine to portray
a young woman who survives a kidnapping
according to bustled on top of
restricting her diet and vitamin intake
to match the experience of her character
Larson also spent six months of
pre-production researching the effects
of abuse and long periods of confinement
after shooting the film Larson emerged
as a powerful voice for survivors of
sexual assault on the same night she
took home the Oscar for Best Actress
she stood up to hug all 50 sexual
assault survivors who had joined Lady
gaga
on stage for an emotional performance in
the years since she's been vocal in
opposing sexual abuse she refused to
applaud for Casey Affleck's Best Actor
win when presenting him with the Oscar
in 2017
telling Vanity Fair that her reaction
quote speaks for itself a reference to a
flex legal battles with two employees
who sued him for sexual harassment
according to indie wire in 2017 Larson
stepped down
an independent collective she co-founded
after allegations of sexual misconduct
on the part of some members were made
public Don Cheadle
for the premiere of 2004 s Hotel Rwanda
Don Cheadle traveled to Uganda in
neighboring Rwanda and the trip
certainly made an impact according to
People magazine after meeting with
genocide survivors he met with the
Rwandan president and toured camps in
Uganda set up for refugees fleeing
violence at the hands of rebel groups
the experience lit a fire inside the
actor who in 2005 made another trip this
time to Sudan where he visited refugee
camps in Darfur Cheadle ended up Co
authoring a book about his experiences
called not on our watch the mission to
end genocide in Darfur and beyond the
book urges US citizens to demand that
their government take action on behalf
of imperiled Nations Cheadle is also on
the board of a charity of the same name
an advocacy group co-founded by George
Clooney Angelina Jolie though the first
Tomb Raider film was popular among fans
of the record-breaking gaming franchise
it would end up sending leading lady
Angelina Jolie's life in an entirely
different direction while working on the
film and its sequel in Cambodia Jolie
became aware of the plight of the
Cambodian people and began relief work
there she was named as a UNHCR goodwill
ambassador in early 2001 less than ten
years later she had visited more than 20
countries around the world bringing
awareness and aid to Sudan Chad
Syria and Iraq among others in 2005 she
launched the National Center for refugee
and immigrant children which provides
free legal aid to asylum seeking
children without representation
according to ABC News after being
awarded Cambodian citizenship for her
work Jolie founded a day care facility
for children with HIV Jennifer Garner
Ben Affleck and Jennifer Garner
announced their plans to divorce in 2015
and when garner was asked how she fared
in the aftermath of the separation she
joked to Vanity Fair that it had been
quote a year of wine it's not surprising
then that miracles from heaven the first
film that thrust her back into the
Hollywood spotlight for the first time
since the divorce announcement was an
emotional experience garner revealed to
People magazine that miracles from
heaven helped her reconnect to her
religion saying when I did move to LA it
wasn't something that was just part of
the culture and
same way at least in my life so it was a
great gift of this film that it took us
back to finding our local Methodist
Church in going every Sunday mary j
blige musician and actor mary j blige
suffered through a very public
separation from her manager and husband
of over a decade
Kendu Isaacs and channeled her pain into
her first starring film role in mud
bound the transformation also had a
profound effect on blige's self-image
she explained to vulture I had to leave
a lot of myself behind a lot of mary j
blige behind a lot of wigs a lot of
lashes a lot of makeup a lot of nails
you know the whole thing blige noted
that stripping down to her natural hair
texture was something that she'd always
feared adding the role stripped me down
all the way to what I truly am and
people were complimenting me people were
saying how beautiful I was I didn't know
I was that beautiful for real I didn't
know that her performance earned her two
Oscar nominations for Best Song and Best
Supporting Actress of the new direction
her character pushed her in blige noted
this is the next chapter it shows that
you know sometimes we have to suffer to
gain and it's I don't mind